All right, so
[LAUGH] what have we learned?
I think you basically convinced
me to do the writing and
now you're the one who has actually
think about what we learned.
>> No, no,
what we'll do is we'll end up sharing.
So you tell me what we've learned and
I'll you if that's right.
>> So there was game theory one and
game theory two and
they had their own what have we
learned along the way, right?
>> Right.
>> All right, so
then what happened when we came back,
there were Scooby Doo noises.
>> There were Scooby Doo noises.
>> Then we talked about-
>> Solution concepts.
>> Exactly, and we listed a bunch,
but we focused in on two of them.
>> Right, and I talked about
correlated equilibrium and
the relationship to Nash equilibria.
And sort of how they're awesome and
efficient to learn or
efficient to compute.
>> What was the main idea for
the equilibrium?
What was the thing that was
introduced that makes it work?
>> Traffic lights.
>> Better known as a shared
source of randomization.
>> Yes, which I don’t think I
ever actually said, but yes.
>> I heard it implicitly.
>> Yeah, it was implicit,
a shared source of randomization.
In other words, that one-third,
one-third that we did with the cards
was something that we both knew
that kind of allowed us to
correlate possible outcomes.
And that is again,
a shared sort of randomization.
And I think even convinced you
that traffic lights are a kind of
randomization from your point
of view when you get there.
>> So it ends up being an easier
solution concept to find the values for,
but it also is it requires more power.
If you don't have your source of
randomization, you can't even use this.
>> That's right, but
it is powerful and it allows us to
often come to a better outcome than
we would with a Nash equilibrium.
>> Some definition of better.
>> Higher expected utility.
>> For both players, for
one player, for the average player.
>> Well, that's on the game.
>> And I think it generalizes
to arbitrary number of players,
but the game made to see
themselves get really big.
If as the number of players grows.
>> But that's true anyway.
>> Yep, exactly.
>> Okay.
>> All right, and then I talk about
a solution concept called coco values
which had an even stronger assumption.
Not just that there's a source of
shared source of randomization,
but there's actually
binding side payments.
Meaning that there's a mechanism for
deciding who gets what once the actions
have been taken and
utilities have been distributed.
>> Right, and this encourages
a player who might not have a reason
to do any particular equilibrium.
To pick one that is beneficial to one of
the other players because that person
will share in the increase benefit.
>> Right, so it encourages a pareto
optimal response that is to say that in
particular they're going to choose
the outcome that has the largest total
reward and then they're
going to divide up that reward.
>> Did you mention greater optimal
when we were talking about this?
>> No.
>> It was implicit much like shared
source of randomization.